-Donald Trump reappeared
on Fox News
for the first time in six months
as he faces
an expected indictment
and ratchets up his attacks on
Florida governor Ron DeSantis,
and Fox, which has
tied itself politically
and financially to Trump,
is clearly torn between
the MAGA base they helped create
and which are desperately
afraid of losing
and their desire
to pivot toward DeSantis,
which doesn't seem
to be working.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Donald Trump has once again
overtaken the news cycle.
So just in case
you've forgotten,
it's worth remembering
that he is
and has always been
deeply unpopular,
and a large majority
of Americans
just want him to go away.
They've said so in three
straight national elections
and over and over again
in countless polls.
Personally, my solution
would be to put him
in a DeLorean with Doc Brown,
send him back to the year 1946,
stop his parents
from conceiving him,
and then nuke
that [bleep] clock tower
so he can't make his way back --
problem solved.
One day we'll just wake up
and he would start
magically disappearing
from photos like Marty McFly.
Remember that when he posed
with a can of beans?
There are so many pictures
where removing Donald Trump
makes it impossible to believe
the missing element
is a former president.
I mean, he was in this picture
with Kid Rock.
That was a president picture.
He was in this picture
with a glowing orb.
That was a president pic--
He was in this picture
with the shocked Easter Bunny.
He was --
A president was there.
Trump must have been so mad
when he saw they got him
an Easter Bunny with glasses.
[ As Trump ] He's a nerd.
I'm not...
taking a picture
with a nerd rabbit.
[ Normal voice ]
Trump's deep unpopularity
was proven yet again
in another poll out this week
where a large majority said
they do not want him
re-elected president.
And even worse for Trump,
the bad news came from Fox.
-61% of people do not want
former President Trump
to be elected again.
-I mean, that's amazing.
61% are already
a hard no on Trump.
And it's not like he can say,
"Yeah, it's 61% now,
but wait until
they get to know me."
We [bleep] know you, dude.
We got to see you do the job
we don't want you to have again.
I mean, we can find someone else
to yell at the kid
mowing the White House lawn.
Oh, that's another good example.
[ Laughter ]
It was a president.
That was a picture
of a president.
But that's the problem
for Republicans.
Trump is deeply unpopular
with the majority of Americans
while also remaining
very popular with the GOP base.
One new poll out this week gave
Trump a 26-point national lead
over Florida governor
Ron DeSantis
and another show that Trump
has actually added to his lead
with a 15-point gain
since December,
while DeSantis
has dropped 12 points.
And that increase
has coincided with Trump
stepping up his attacks
on DeSantis on social media,
at his rallies, and on Fox News.
In an interview with
Sean Hannity on Monday night,
Trump laid into DeSantis
and claimed his political career
would be dead
without Trump's endorsement
back in 2018.
-So what happened with Ron
is the following.
He came to see me.
He was getting killed.
He was being crushed.
Ron came to see me,
tears in his eyes.
He said, "I need you
to do me a big favor."
First he asked for the meeting,
then he asked me for the favor.
I said, "What's the favor?"
"Would you endorse me?"
He said,
"I need your endorsement."
I said, "Ron,
you're so far behind,
I can't imagine that if you got
George Washington's endorsement
combined with the great --
late great Abraham Lincoln,
if you had their endorsements,
I don't think you could win,
Ron, but tell me about it,
go ahead."
He said, "I'm telling you,
I think I could win
if I could get
your endorsement."
-Alright, first of all,
why is George Washington
just George Washington
but Abraham Lincoln
is the late great Abraham?
I'm certain that's the extent
of Trump's knowledge
about Abraham Lincoln.
If you asked him
to say anything else,
it would just turn
into word soup.
[ As Trump ] Abraham Lincoln,
he was definitely great,
and he is definitely late,
AKA dead.
He died.
He died so tragically
when John Wilkes
jumped out of a phone booth...
and said, "Your hat
or your life."
But Lincoln, he couldn't
take off his hat.
People don't know that.
He couldn't take off his hat
because it was a stovepipe
and therefore hot to the touch.
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ]
Trump then continued
with his attacks on DeSantis.
-I said, "Let's give it a shot,
Ron, okay?"
And he was desperate.
I said, "Okay."
I gave him a nice endorsement.
I said, "You write out what
you'd like and let me see it."
He wrote it out.
I thought it was terrible.
I changed it, made it great.
I gave him a great endorsement.
From the moment
I pressed that button,
he blew the guy away.
The race was over.
And I said, "Ron,
you can beat this guy.
Let's go."
I got him the nomination.
By the way, could have never
gotten the nomination.
He would be working in either
a pizza parlor place
or a law office right now.
-You know Trump is a New Yorker
because the only two professions
he can think of
are pizza parlor and law office.
[ Laughter ]
Although Trump has clearly
never been inside
a pizza place himself,
given that he refers to it
as a "pizza parlor place."
[ Laughter ]
Sounds like a Russian spy
whose submarine ran aground
on Staten Island.
[ Russian accent ] Where is
your nearest pizza parlor place?
My stomach is barking
like dog mouth,
and I could consume
multiple triangle slices.
[ Laughter ]
Triangle is most
delicious shape.
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ]
So Trump is trashing DeSantis,
which has apparently
been helping him in
GOP primary polls,
even though he's still
incredibly unpopular
with the rest of the electorate.
And that's the inherent
problem for Fox News.
They helped create this monster,
and now, seeing that it's been
a catastrophic failure,
they've been trying
to tiptoe away from Trump.
But their viewers,
the Trump base, won't have it.
It's like the story
of Frankenstein's monster,
except in this version,
the villagers [bleep]
love the monster.
"Hey, you're the monster.
Dude, I love your work.
Would you sign my pitchfork?"
That's why Fox originally
tried to ditch Trump
after the 2020 election
and subsequent coup attempt
but then turned around
and embraced
his insane conspiracy theories,
even though they knew they were
insane and said so in private.
Rupert Murdoch wrote
in an e-mail
after the insurrection
that Fox host Sean Hannity
had been "privately disgusted
by Trump for weeks,
but was scared to lose viewers."
And after the election,
Hannity sent a text that said...
They were so scared.
I can only imagine
what Hannity was doing
when he sent that text.
He was probably
lying on the floor
watching election returns
with...
-Tears in his eyes.
-But that's the modern
conservative movement
in a microcosm right there.
Donald Trump's
twisted relationship
with the most powerful
right-wing propaganda outlet
in the country, Fox News, has
been a decade-long soap opera
that the rest of us
have sadly had to live with,
despite the fact
that everyone involved sucks.
It's very much an
"Alien vs. Predator" situation
where sometimes the alien
and the predator are friends,
sometimes the alien
and the predator bicker,
but mostly the alien
has a huge MAGA fan base --
make aliens great again --
that the Predator News network
is desperately afraid of losing,
and the alien knows that.
So anytime he doesn't like
the coverage he's getting
from the Predator channel,
he does a rally
where he complains
about their anti-alien bias.
That explains why when I turned
into Trump's rally on Saturday,
he sounded like this.
[ Alien screeching ]
[ Laughter ]
Fox has put themselves
in a situation
where they've tied their
financial and political success
to Trump and his base,
a base they helped create.
But now that Trump is under
multiple criminal investigations
and has tanked the GOP
in those three successive
national elections,
Fox is gently trying to nudge
their audience toward DeSantis
without pissing them off.
For example,
after Trump attacked DeSantis,
Fox host Brian Kilmeade
criticized Trump
the next morning.
-With Ron DeSantis,
he sees a threat,
but I think that his best
offense as the front-runner
would be don't punch down.
-All Donald Trump knows
is punching down.
Telling Trump not to punch down
would be like
telling Don Rickles
not to antagonize the audience.
Sorry, the late great
Don Rickles.
One half of the comedy duo
Rickles and Lincoln.
[ Laughter ]
Then there was Fox personality
Jason Chaffetz,
who didn't like how much Trump
whined during the interview.
-Jason, you said overall,
you thought President Trump
did a very poor job
in the interview.
Why?
-I thought Sean Hannity
did a good job,
but I watched that
and I thought,
"Where is Donald Trump?"
I voted for Donald Trump twice.
I have defended him
countless times.
I thought he was horrific.
I think that was
the worst interview
I've seen the president do.
He was whining.
He was complaining.
He played the victim card
time and time again.
And then after that,
he complained
that, you know,
somebody he had endorsed
was now running against him.
And I thought he was
absolutely horrific.
He's the former president
of the United States.
Act like it.
He didn't in that interview.
-I'm sorry. Which Donald Trump
were you expecting?
The Donald Trump who whines,
complains,
and plays the victim card
or the Donald Trump
who doesn't [bleep] exist
because there's only
the first one?
He's got two shticks, punching
down and playing the victim.
That's it.
That's the whole deal.
And as much as the rest of us
hate it, for Republican voters,
that's not a negative for Trump.
That's why he's
the GOP front-runner.
Either these guys
still don't get it
or they're just pretending
not to get it
because they don't want to admit
that they've devoted their lives
to a morally and ideologically
bankrupt political movement
whose main goals
are cutting taxes,
making it easier
for people to get guns,
and losing their [bleep]
over the fact
that the green M&M doesn't
give them a boner anymore.
The only genuine belief
Donald Trump has,
as far as I can tell,
is that democracy is for losers
and some form of dictatorship
would be much better.
He basically came out
and said as much
in the second part
of his interview
with Hannity last night.
Trump praised
China's totalitarian regime
when he was asked
if presidential candidates
should have to take
a cognitive test.
-I'd like to see it for
anybody running for president.
I think somebody
running for president
taking a cognitive test --
You know, they do it in China.
But it's done a different way.
They have a caste system.
And the smartest person
gets to the top.
-First of all, that's definitely
not how a caste system works.
[ Laughter ]
Even when he's saying
he should get the job
because he's smarter,
he's dumb as [bleep]
No one who's actually smart
has to explain a caste system
by doing this with their hands.
He looks like he's playing
one of those
rhyming games for children.
[ As Trump ] Here's the church,
here's the steeple,
here's the caste system
with all the smartest people.
That's how it works, Sean.
[ Normal voice ]
Fox and the conservative
movement created a monster,
and now they're trying
to free themselves from it.
But so far, it's not working.
Trump is the star
of a political movement
that they built,
a movement built on victimhood,
persecution, and wanting
to have sex with M&M's.
And as we all know,
when it comes to having sex
with an M&M...
-The smartest person
gets to the top.
[ Laughter ]
-During the commercial,
let's all think about that.
[ Laughter ]
This has been "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]